what's up believe nation happy Thursday
I am testing something new entrepreneur
AMA asked me anything I'm on my
trampoline so I'll try not to do too
much balancing because that's probably
pretty distracting for you guys to watch
uh I always do my live hangouts and
interviews and all that stuff on
Thursdays and I wanted to have a place
where you guys go ask your questions a
lot of the time you're asking questions
the comments and it just takes too much
time to respond to everybody in the
bajillion so I thought hey let's let's
come here like come here and ask the
question I'm also trying to do my main
interviews at 11:00 on Thursdays where
possible so the goal is every Thursday
at 11:00 a.m. Eastern to do a live
stream with you guys
either just me answering your questions
or with a special guest on board we'll
see that's the goal we'll see if you
guys like it we'll see if we can execute
and keep on the schedule but let's get
in the way guys leave your questions I
see people already joining in leaving
questions this is awesome let's get to
the top whoever has the first question
make a video and Logan Paul uh yeah we
even done looking Paul did we do the
other Paul what's the other who's the
other Paul Logan Paul and his brother
none of the Sean Paul Wow Lilly Wow
Lilly Sean paw food is here Logan Paul
and Sean Paul are not brothers um I'm
blanking anyway for the top tens we have
the list go to the description of most
of the videos there's a place you can go
you vote the more people vote on those
names that's how we pick like it's
always combination of what you guys want
plus what we have enough content that I
like that we can put together a series
on next Tullio some yahwah Tulio's on my
yahwah Evan please help me I have a big
problem with my willpower it's really
hard for me when I feel lazy to do
something how do i erase that feeling I
actually have a good video coming up
with seven ways series and how to stay
focused that I just recorded yesterday
yesterday is my crazy filming day we did
6070 videos so that was fun
quick highlight so for you one I don't
believe people are just naturally
inherently lazy I think they just have
goals that aren't exciting for them I
think they're doing work isn't
motivating like you've had
tons of moments in your life where you
felt motivated on fire to go and do
something and so you just a combination
of one you're not passionate about it
like you don't like the work that you're
doing and you can only force yourself to
do something for so long before you quit
like how long are you willing to do this
thing that you hate where it's not
really gonna be the best use of your
time because if you are walking around
and going to work and working on
projects and you just feel the weight of
the world on you and it's stressful and
it sucks and you're being lazy you're
not doing anything that's waste of time
that's wasted time that should be
spending something that you are
passionate and excited about and one of
the most common rules that keeps coming
up Oh guys look what's that on my desk
ah ah videos coming out tomorrow we did
the unboxing that's a that's a demo test
cover that jr. is made for us but the
top ten rules of success the book look
at that ah exciting so it's going
through my test audience um this is the
very first video that the book is is
making its way into anyway so one of the
one of the top ten rules like one of the
most common things that keep coming up
over and over and over again is you
gotta work your passion but successful
people do work that they are passionate
about and it's for entrepreneurs
musicians actors across any field the
people the top to the work they love and
if you don't love your work then you're
gonna feel lazy if you ask me to go help
entrepreneurs I like I love beat this
does not work for me I love this like
how do I carve out time in my calendar
to make this happen versus if you were
to ask you to go do something I hate
yeah I'm gonna procrastinate yeah I'm
gonna be lazy yeah I'm gonna not want to
do that work and so it's really
important to do the thing that you love
the second thing that kind of ties into
it is also making making you feel like
the work you're doing has meaning is
having an impact if you feel like the
work that you're doing is not having an
impact then it's really hard to keep
going it's really hard to keep the
motivation high you know my first
business that was a struggle because I
love the work that I was doing but we
weren't getting results and so I wasn't
feeling like the work I did mattered and
maybe it's just me but I really like
feeling like the things that I do matter
you know if I'm coming here and doing a
live stream I want you guys to care when
you guys ask
questions if you're not answering
questions asking questions if nobody's
showing up like well forget this I'm not
doing this anymore so I'm having an
impact and so I think that combination
if you're doing work that you love and
doing work that is having an impact you
won't be lazy and I think that's a much
better strategy to try to figure out
that path instead of forcing yourself to
do something that you don't like next
holy cow questions are are plowing
through let's see what we've got
i u'b hi I mean who is the best
motivational speaker in the world in
your opinion it's a personal preference
thing I think some people like being
yelled at some people love the in your
face up front personality you like the
Eric Thomas and the Joe Rogan and the
Jocko will link and the people who kind
of screaming at you some people like the
softer more subtle approach some people
love the Wayne Dyer who's so full and
will give you a hug so I don't know that
there's a best I think it's the one that
you resonate the most with and I think
if you find the person that you resonate
really well with then try to consume
more of their content as much as
possible so as an example Alex came to
me at Toronto events also on Monday and
showed me this clip from somebody we've
had on the channel I'm blanking on
everybody's name today he'd never heard
of this guy before and I said listen
I've interviewed that guy he's he has
his own YouTube channel like if you like
what he's saying the the message that
he's seen is not that different than the
message of other people are saying but
the words that he's using the
expressions the tone the way he's saying
it for whatever reason just hit Alex
really hard it's a great if listening to
this guy makes you feel inspired and
motivated go do amazing work then put
him on every day right that's the guy
for you even if other people may not
care as much about him for me I love
Young Les Brown Young Les Brown is the
jam for me I love the young Les Brown
content we've done a ton of videos on
him you can go back on the channel and
find them and that's my favorite but I
don't know that I would say he's the
best I think he just got to find the one
that's best for you next hayamin Shelly
Shelly and Dawkins hi Evan from London
UK I'm in the process
launching a business as a motivational
speaker I would like someone as a mentor
can you recommend anybody so a couple
things here one you can watch the
unlocking Lily series that Lily is doing
on my channel I stole Lily away from her
full-time job and she is basically
mentoring under me to become a speaker I
would say motivational speaker but to
become a full-time speaker build a
business around it and every two weeks
is an episode on the channel that is
highlighting her journey so she just
came back from her first TEDx talk and
basically you see her growth and her
development everything she's learning on
the way to becoming a full-time speaker
and building the business around it I
think that's a great series to help you
I don't know if other people have done
like the journey to becoming a
professional speaker that you could you
could learn from I think watching
speakers you can learn a lot from like
I've had know the best mentors that I've
had from a business perspective are a
lot of people behind me here and most of
them have never met
you know there's aspirational mentors
people you can learn from and if you're
around on my consistent basis it it just
it brings that consciousness into you
you see how they act you see the words
they're saying you see how they're using
their hands and their stories they're
telling and you start to learn from them
and I think I would try to surround
myself with as much a special mentors as
possible in terms of meeting people
one-on-one like somebody who can
actually go and have a coffee with you
know you may not be able to get a Les
Brown to do that but you could get
somebody on a smaller scale especially
at the beginning but don't go in this is
a mistake a lot of entrepreneurs make
you go in asking for mentorship and
mentorship is a relationship it's a
long-term relationship it's a commitment
that you're asking for so you're asking
for something big from them you're
asking for the most important thing that
they have which is their time and so
people like to give back but most
mentees suck and that's the truth most
mentees suck most mentees you tell them
what did you give them advice you listen
to them you give them wise counsel and
then they don't do anything and so
that's the challenge because you're
labeled you're bunch thing with all
these other crappy mentees and you have
the show that you're not going to be
someone who wastes their time just like
all these other people have
and so people love giving back but to my
point in the first question people love
also feeling like the work they're doing
is meaningful and so if I'm spending
time with somebody and they're not doing
the work then I feel like I wasted my
time and then I'm jaded the next time
right and then I've set up walls and
barriers because if that keeps happening
then the 1% of people will actually take
action have a hard time getting through
because of all the 99 people who sucked
and so don't go in asking for mentorship
go in asking for 10 minutes of their
time to ask one question and figure out
what the most important question is for
you go out and find a way to do it
one girl wrote to me once and said Evan
I want your opinion on something I'll
come to Toronto I want to meet you
let's meet over coffee or I'll buy you
coffee or if it's just walking to your
car
on a on a Thursday afternoon I will ask
you my question then and I'll bring
cookies right like showing the drive
showing the hustle and I gave her some
time and so starting off easy starting
off with one small ask and then whatever
advice to give you
yeah you got your one question out
whatever advice to give you go and do
something about it before you ever come
back again we're what most mentees do is
they'll ask that question they won't
take any action because it's too hard or
too scary is too difficult or whatever
other limiting beliefs that they have
and then they come back and ask another
question like don't ask a second
question until you did the first thing
even if you didn't do it why Lord failed
or didn't work or you tried it 100 times
and it's still didn't work out like you
put in the effort that's what mentors
want to see that you're putting in the
effort and so that's how you start one
question ten minutes get some feedback
do something about it and that gives you
then the permission to come back with a
second question and if that keeps
happening like if you keep coming back
with one question you respect their time
you go out and take massive action
against it then eventually that can
build into a mentorship relationship but
going in and saying to somebody when
will you be my mentor if it's somebody
who's had a lot of success they just did
not let me attack him because they're
going to be afraid that they're just
going to waste their time on you that
you're going to be another
deadbeat mentee that doesn't do anything
and so make it easy for them to say yes
that's what I got I got I got I got I
talked about you Lily you left Lily was
in the washroom you missed it I talked
about you all right what do we got Oh
what do we got what do we got uh
questions questions Aris ah what is your
favorite business book so the two books
that I've always loved is the 4-hour
workweek not that the idea of working
for hours is really appealing and you
look at Tim Ferriss he doesn't work four
hours a week he works way more but the
idea of just delegating and not doing
anything myself and creating systems and
procedures really helped me build my
business but I'm not the one doing
everything all the time and then
radicals and visionaries was another
book by Thaddeus wad row and it's
basically it's basically an older
version of this kind of what he would do
is take I figured how many stories let's
say thirty different entrepreneurs
seamus entrepreneurs and tell their
stories in four to five pages it was his
words it was here's what Jeff Bezos did
to become successful and a lot of
entrepreneurs that maybe a little older
school and their business of you know
their business aren't around anymore so
it's may be harder to relate to but I
love reading that every morning this is
before my YouTube channel came out
before YouTube was a big thing I would
sit down and my desk before working and
read one story of a famous entrepreneur
and it gave me the inspiration and also
gave me ideas it gave me inspiration
that like this person was able to have
success and they started off in a worse
position too when I'm at right now and
you know they could do it I could do it
and it also gave me some ideas it's like
here's how they did it I can do it too
and so that's also the idea for this
book here there's a big warning page
like page three or four in there that
says don't read this book like a book I
don't want you to just plow through the
book it's an easy read but what I want
you to do is there's two rules on each
page but if you're flipping open let me
show you I'm still in like this just
came last night right so I'm still in
like oh my god it's a new book it's so
exciting so like here's Steve Jobs right
so you got Steve
and there's one page so two rules on
this page so what I want you to do is
just read that page read two rules every
day two rules and then do something
about it so it's meant to be an easy
thing that you can you can look at on a
regular basis every day set your date
it's like - the best thing Steve Jobs
has ever said in his life gifted to you
read it and do something about it and so
radicals and visionaries was a kind of
version of that and so I really enjoyed
that book that's what I got but I think
this is gonna be my favorite book I mean
both of these books are great but
they're my own so you gotta love what
you do you know I love what you create
next Tony Q should I write down small
goals every morning to help keep myself
focused I love doing my work but my mind
gets fuzzy until I get into that drive
so I think as an entrepreneur what we
contend to do is always be dreaming now
I'd be thinking about the big picture
wherever you want to go and that's great
like you need that vision you need the
big picture you need to have that you
know mission that's driving you forward
but you don't get that mission
accomplished you don't actually get
stuff done just by thinking about things
right like the planning can be fun of
how you're gonna make stuff happen but
then you have to still go and make stuff
happen and so I think you should be
spending at least 80% of your time
actually doing when you wake up and you
don't have to think about what you're
going to do today you have a schedule
you have it find out you know what your
goals are and then when things when you
get inspired maybe read a book maybe you
watch your video maybe have a
conversation maybe you're having a
shower a new inspiration hits then you
can adjust your schedule to make it
happen but I think people who wake up at
least for me like if I woke up I didn't
know what I was doing today I wouldn't
be as productive I wouldn't be doing
nothing but I wouldn't be as productive
or now Thursday is my public-facing day
I'm doing interviews all day long and
meeting people it's boom boom boom in
two different sessions and and I love
that and so I think what's really
helpful at least for me is I wake up
part of my morning ritual is I look at
what my day is supposed to be today so
Thursday's public-facing day Thursday I
need to have my extroverted energy on I
need to go out and have hopefully some
inspiring conversation with an
entrepreneur
and I have you know my goals written
down for what I want to accomplish on
that day so the combination of the goals
and the schedule of here's what here's
how my time is allocated and making sure
that your goals match your schedule if
you have your goals that are I want to
do this but then if you look at how
you're spending your time it doesn't
sync up like the actions you're taking
don't help you achieve your goals it's
gonna be a problem right but I don't
want to think about that every day I
don't want to wake up and think huh
there's my schedule match my goals every
day it's too much thinking and less
doing and so there'll be times and it's
not it's not scheduled in but let's say
once a month where I'll look at my
calendar and say okay you know what like
this doesn't feel right you know I
should be doing more I need this thing
doesn't is not giving me enough leverage
I don't want to do that thing anymore
this test worked and I need to do more
this test didn't work and ain't around
once a month I'll do that kind of
analysis but it's it's more of a feeling
when I feel like something's a little
bit out of whack then I look at my
schedule but for most days I wake up I
remember what I want to do I want to
help a billion entrepreneurs I look at
my calendar here's what I need to get
done today I look at my goals for the
day and then I just do and I spend most
of my day doing and I think most
entrepreneurs don't spend enough time
doing you spend too much time thinking
and planning and dreaming which is
necessary but you're just finding too
much time thinking about it instead of
actually going up and doing it next
heaven what is a failure that you learn
the most from was the best advice you
never followed was let me save that cuz
I'm probably forget the second question
the biggest Fila that I think the
biggest failure that I learned the most
from was probably the girl in Paris
story that I've told a couple times in
my channel where I was in Paris I was 18
years old it was a you know summer trip
and I was there by myself and I had my
map open I was looking for directions
and this girl comes up to me in perfect
French asking for directions and I'm
first thinking why is this girls in
perfect French asked me for directions
because she should probably know where
she's going she's local but I wanted to
ask her out and long story short I was
too afraid I was too afraid you know I
thought my French wasn't good enough and
these reasons why I shouldn't ask her to
a coffee or a drink and and so she
walked away she walked away and then I
felt like men like why did I do that why
did I let that happen well what was I so
afraid of like it's the rejection that
painful and what I did was I took a
picture and you see pictures on the wall
here behind me like these mean something
to me I took a picture of where she was
walking and she just walked behind my
stall that's why she didn't get her in
the picture and it looks like this just
beautiful kind of French Riverside
picture and I printed it up giant like
this I put it on my wall where I was
kind of staying and I looked at that
picture every day and people came into
my room said wow what a beautiful
picture like yeah that's from France but
really that picture reminded me daily
that the next time I want to do
something and I'm afraid I don't want to
regret it I want to say yes to it even
if I'm afraid and so that I try to make
that future fear of regret be bigger
than the immediate fear of whatever I'm
about to do so the fear of you know
years of not knowing and kicking myself
I make that bigger than the immediate
fear of asking that girl out and so it's
not for me at least it's not forget the
fear pretend like the fear doesn't exist
or just you know ignore it like no the
fear is there it's real I just make
another fear bigger than that fear and
so I have to go into action and that's
what helped me start the next business
so the next year I got the opportunity
to join a company a startup and I had
opportunities to join companies making
80 hundred K per year starting salary
that everybody wanted in my in my class
that year and I said no I'm going to
take this $300 a month job because I
didn't want to regret it I knew I could
go get another job may not be the same
company may not be as good pay but if
you get another job later I didn't know
if I have the same kind of startup
opportunity again and so I had to go out
and do that thing and that became
because of that Paris event and ever
since it's been one of the most
important lessons that I learned and I'm
lucky that I learned that you know at 18
years old that anytime I feel like I
might regret not doing something then I
know I have to go and do it and I'm
still apply that to my life now last
year last year when they go to climate
con well this year this year this year I
still do it it was this year there was
this event in California called climber
con and was a networking event for
youtubers and I hate networking events I
never go to networking events unless I'm
speaking if I'm speaking as a different
story but just just going as at a
participant I never do it I haven't done
it for like a decade and here was this
event and as all these youtubers with a
hundred thousand plus subscribers so
it's supposed to be you know higher
level youtubers it was interesting and I
got invited to go and I eyed hamed then
I HOD and I you know was on the French
for the longest time and then I just
decided you know what if I don't go I
might regret it and so I went and used
to thing it was just okay like was it
worth three to four days of my time
maybe did it suck no was it amazing no
but knowing is better than not knowing
knowing and even failing like even if it
was the biggest bomb ever and I came
home early and I wasted thousands of
dollars that's okay
because knowing is better than not
knowing I didn't want to be looking out
you know five years what if I just went
to that event you know I I still regret
like that regret will eat you up and
kill you so nobody is better than not
knowing so it's one of the most
important lessons that I learned ever in
my life I learned it at 18 and I still
use it today
and the second part of that was what was
advice that I received that I as so many
questions coming in that I didn't listen
to I don't remember I don't remember to
be honest I have a hard time with a lot
of these like past looking questions
because I don't live in the past past
failures like even pulling that those
ones out I have to remember because I
get asked those questions so often but I
don't remember when I started my youtube
channel I don't remember a lot of the
past details I'm just focused on where
I'm going and and there's been so many
series that we've canceled on this
YouTube channel so a serious it didn't
work I don't remember 95% of them even
though I
love them like I don't put out a series
that I don't think is gonna be like if
they think it's gonna be a loser I'm not
gonna do it right it's it's a video that
I love I love this series I'm putting up
I'm proud of it I want my grandkids to
see it but doesn't mean that they all
work but I don't remember what those
field ones were I think if you just live
in the fail the failure like all this
stuff didn't work and you live in your
past and you're never actually doing
anything like now in the moment and so
I'm much more now in forward-facing than
then past but it's a great question I
just don't have an interview creator
fundamentals
okay so Evan where are you going what's
your end goal I'm gonna have the Billie
entrepreneurs that's the goal I think
entrepreneurs will solve all the world's
major problems and I can't do a lot of
those like I can only do so much I can
only do a tiny little piece right I
can't solve cancer I can't stop wars I
can't you know help economies but
entrepreneurs can and so I want to help
the guy or the girl who's gonna go and
solve cancer who is considering two
career paths whether to you know go do
this safe practical boring thing or
start your own business and try to solve
cancer I want to help try to be that
little half percent difference that
gears them towards entrepreneurship and
helping them stay on their path rather
than a life that's less than their
potential and so I figure if I can do
that a billion times that's gonna have
massive impact around the world and it's
a lifetime goal it's a it's a it's an
it's an impossible goal so it's a never
achieved goal it's a mission right like
your mission is never done it's always
ongoing more work to be done and so
that's I have I have that as my lifetime
goal and then I only have really short
term goals so it's I want to be I want
to have a million YouTube subscribers by
the end of the year right that's the
goal looks like we're gonna hit it
thank you guys I love you guys but I
don't know what five years looks like
like if you ask me five years ago I
would never have said I'd have two books
out I have a youtube channel with all
that almost a million subscribers like
that part that stuff wasn't on my radar
I wasn't taking any of that stuff here
so I was doing other stuff and so are we
gonna be in five years
I don't know maybe I'm not
on YouTube anymore maybe we're doing VR
stuff like maybe we're in something
totally different I'm always gonna do
the thing that I'm passionate about and
that helps me accomplish my big goal and
so I'm very much in the lifetime goal
and the short-term goals and everything
in between takes care of itself I figure
it out along the way
as soon as I come up with a five-year
goal and maybe this is my problem as
soon as I come up with here's what I
want to do in five years that's not
acceptable to me I have to find a way to
just get started now the idea of
delaying something and waiting for
something else to happen is not I can't
handle it I maybe I'm too ad DS like I
need to go out and do it that stuff has
to get done ASAP we're working on it now
and between the five-year goal into a
five-month goal or a five-week goal and
we just start doing it what else we're
running out of time man half an hour is
flying by quick what else
rod thank you for the great answers that
the videos keep doing you're doing thank
you rod what tip mr. truffle pigs what
tip would you give to change one day to
day one I've been in a mental hole for
ages to two bits of advice for you here
mr. truffle pigs one is make it more
important so one is think about the
value that you want to create the life
that you're going to be able to live the
impact you're gonna have and if you're
not gonna do it for yourself then then
maybe it's your your family maybe it's
your spouse and visit your kids members
your community maybe it's a country like
where do you have that passionate
connection to that you can tie into and
then the other side of that coin is what
happens if you don't do it so what you
it's not day one yet it's one day still
for you are you gonna be happy if in
five years it's still one day you know
like try to try to just like the regret
thing for me try to compound it it's
like 20 years of one day what's gonna
happen like you'll miss your opportunity
somebody else will make millions of
dollars off of your idea and remind
yourself of that and then bring that
back to today and just make it insanely
painful so I do I just make it insanely
painful that I then have to go and take
that action but that only works in short
bursts I find like
don't that little motivation it's hard
to do that every single day and so what
I find really helpful is then part two
of this is to have an environment that
really supports you thinking bigger
every day so if your challenge is
staying focused or if your challenge is
getting started or if your challenge is
believing in yourself more then I would
try this around myself and create an
environment for myself that allowed that
to happen every day so as an example for
me it started with the book write that
book I was talking about before and now
translate to this like why do I
recommend you read one page a day in
this book because you're gonna get two
ideas from people who accomplish amazing
things and you're doing it every day
like if you start your day with
something every single day that gets you
feeling like you can accomplish
something imagine what's gonna happen to
you in a year or in five years or in ten
years if you kept that habit up it's
much more about your habits and your
routine in your environment because
it'll start shaping your beliefs and
your actions and so I walk in here and I
see these people behind me right that
motivates me to to want to do more work
you might look at this wall and not know
how these people or hate Steve Jobs so
that's great like put the thing up on
your wall that gets you fired up watch
the videos that get you fired up you may
love my channel you may hate my chatting
I think is the worst thing ever great
don't watch my channel in the morning if
my channel gets you fired up then watch
it every day it's why I created the end
spresso series it's a it's a shot every
morning for you and so when you've we've
all had those moments in our lives that
have led to us feeling bold unstoppable
you know turning that one day to day one
what were you doing that led to that
we're watching a video where you reading
the book where you're having a
conversation like what were you doing
what triggered that thought process for
you and then bring that into your daily
routine every day that's what you want
to start with so you start your day fire
it up feeling courageous feeling
unstoppable I think if you do that
consistently you do that every day
you'll find that you're constantly
taking action on that idea that you have
creator fundamentals thank you for the
super chat first super chat of the day I
haven't done a lot of super chat stuff I
guess I haven't got a lot of live chat
stuff I appreciate that
creator fundamentals dropping $5 thank
you for the love man
after this I'm gonna go bye
Coffee thanks to you creative
fundamentals well said thanks to your
time guys we're time it's 11:30 it's
crazy how quickly half an hour goes I'm
gonna try to continue to do this every
week Thursday the same time 11:00 a.m.
Eastern either by myself or with a guest
and hopefully we can have some fun
together get inspired together help
answer your questions this was the first
test series so hopefully you guys had a
good time I appreciate the love we still
have a lot of time left in this day to
go out and have an amazing time I'm
doing one live interview on the other
channel and then everything else is on
other people's channels you can't tune
in or meetings but having a raise have
an amazing have an amazing rest of the
day that means of raising amazing than
rest and thank you for the love guys you
guys keep me fired up to do this every
day - I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever say it with me your one word is
what you love guys we'll see you soon